there is practically no need for any
introduction
most of us Godzilla was first seen in a
2014 movie and made his second
appearance in a 2019 movie as the
ultimate king of the monsters anyway
just for a quick recap a quickie
Godzilla 2019 is 393 feet tall which is
almost a hundred and 20 meters in height
and weighs in and about a hundred
thousand tons he is an ancient Permian
age super species that lived for
millions of years and hibernated in
pockets of geothermal radiation sources
until awaken in 1945 by the atomic bombs
he and other super species are now
called as Titans with the genus name
being Titanes his skin is nearly
impenetrable his claws and feet are
super tough his tail can wreck almost
anything in its path he has the ability
to absorb nuclear explosions and
radiation and become even stronger and
bigger
above all he has a superpower called the
atomic breath which is a radiation flame
that can blast anything into smithereens
another rare power is his atomic pulse
which is like a thermonuclear shockwave
of thousands of degrees in temperature
and his ability to turn into a super
fight Godzilla but can only become so
under special conditions the mind flayer
also known as the shadow monster is a
malevolent entity that rules a parallel
dimension known as the upside down he
was introduced in the second season of
stranger things and serves as the main
antagonist of the series the mind flayer
is a massively powerful being of unknown
origin he wields supreme control of the
upside down with murderous intent he
repeatedly attempts to corrupt both
Hawkins town and the wider world
the mind flayer first began his conquest
to take over the world in 1984 when he
used the gate to spread to the upside
down toxic biological growth underneath
Hawkins as well as possessing will bias
and an army of demo dogs to take down
Hawkins lab 11 ended his plan by closing
the gate and severac the connection
between the two worlds the part of the
mind flayer remained dominant ill it was
reawakened in 1985 but a Hawkins key it
then began fleeing multiple humans and
rats
into puddles of biomass that would be
used to create a new body for itself to
take over the world
the mind flayer nearly succeeded in his
plan but was killed when the humans
close the gates averring the connection
and once again the mind flayer
is a gargantuan entity being at least
fifty stories tall on more than 540 feet
in height that is a hundred and
sixty-five meters in the metric system
the details of this Anatomy remains
unclear due to the thick silver black
mist which envelops him it is unclear
whether he is entirely composed of this
substance or if his body contains any
solid elements the creature has multiple
limbs most of which branch into several
smaller appendages these limbs virtually
resemble the tendrils and vines present
in the upside down he seems to have
elongated flame shape head which sprouts
from the central body his presence is
often accompanied by unnatural red
lightning which will describes as a
storm true Estela fatigue linked the
mind flayer could directly control
additional entities and beings the mind
flayers 1985 proxy body resembled a
gargantuan monstrous spider this
incarnation of the flayer
closely matches its upside-down
counterpart in terms of its shape and
proportions however unlike the Flay's
main body his proxy is not shrouded in
silver black myths nor is it as large
though it still stands tall at over 20
feet in his fully formed state but
remains vulnerable to heat so what would
happen if most of us Godzilla met and
battled with the mind Flay of stranger
things
let's take in the biggest version of
both monsters which is 2019 Godzilla and
a stranger things season - shadow
monster from the upside down the mind
flayer takes the first point with its
height being more than 540 feet or 165
meters compared to Godzilla's 393 feet
or 120 meters the weight however can be
given to Godzilla as he weighs in at
around a hundred thousand tonnes while
the mind Flay is covered with mist and a
body seems fluid and gaseous in nature
the mind Flay has telepathic control
over additional beings so it can be
implied that he will use this power
against the g-man
but since Godzilla resisted and even
challenged the Alpha call of Ghidorah he
would also shake it off and
this mind game Godzilla seems to have an
advantage over the shadow monster in
physical strength and would wipe the
flow cleaner in its head but this
monster is made of a different substance
which seems to be able to face and
recombine therefore making it hard for
the big J to land a solid blow all this
would end up in a standstill and nothing
would seem to work for both sides until
Godzilla uses his atomic breath and
since the mind Flay is vulnerable to
heap it will not be able to stand
against it moreover in any case if the
mind Flay decides to stand up again the
thermonuclear pulse will render it
helpless but it's not as simple as it
looks the mind Flay is immortal and can
regenerate to its former self given
enough time but then again Godzilla is
near immortal himself and would seek to
destroy the mind flayer wherever he is
resurrected as he poses a threat to the
natural order it will be a cat-and-mouse
game forever just like how Godzilla
hunts to kill the 2014 parasitic Muto's
so thank you for watching this video
please commend your thoughts and do you
like share and subscribe for more videos
about monsters guys you and all those
good stuff